we are now going to discuss price
elasticity of demand which sounds like a
very fancy concept but really it's a way
for economists to sense how sensitive is
quantity to change in prices and in this
video we're going to denote it as a
capital e so e price elasticity of
demand and the easy way to think about
it is it is your percent change in I'll
use the Greek letter Delta shorthand for
change in your percent change in
quantity over your percent change in
price and so you might say wait how does
this relate to the everyday idea of
elasticity
well imagine two bands so let's imagine
an inelastic band in elastic right over
here and let's imagine an elastic band
right over here so in an inelastic band
if we apply some amount of force you're
not going to be able to stretch it much
it might stretch a little bit what an
elastic band if you apply that same
amount of force you might be able to
stretch it a lot more and so the analogy
here is we're not using force but we're
saying how much does quantity stretch
for a given amount of price change and
so something where the quantity changes
a lot for a given price change would be
very elastic so this the magnitude of
this will be larger and if the percent
change in quantity doesn't change a lot
for a given percent change in price well
then we're dealing with an inelastic
price elasticity of demand and we'll be
able to internalize these more as we
work through the numbers and actually
let's do that for this demand schedule
that we have right over here and it's
visualized as our demand curve in the
vertical axis we have price of burgers
and then in our horizontal axis we have
quantity in terms of burgers per hour
and so let's just use this definition of
price elasticity of demand to calculate
it across different points on our demand
curve so let me make a new column here
so price elasticity of demand and the
way I'm going to do it is really the
simplest method for calculating this
in other videos we can go into more
in-depth methods like the midpoint
method and I'll show you the weakness in
what we're doing right here but for the
sake of say an AP economics
microeconomics course this would be
sufficient so let's think about our
price elasticity of demand as we go from
point A to point B well remember that's
just going to be our percent change in
quantity over our percent change in
price so what is our percent change in
quantity well we're starting at a
quantity of two so put that in our
denominator and we're going from two to
four so we are adding two so we have 2
over two we could multiply that times
one hundred percent if we like so this
would give us we have a hundred percent
change in quantity over now what was the
corresponding change in price percent
change in price so our corresponding
percent change in price
our initial price is nine and we go from
nine to eight so we're going down by one
and then we multiply that times one
hundred percent so this is going to be
about a negative 11 percent change in
price and this math is reasonably
straightforward because the hundred
percents cancel out this is just a 1 1
over negative 1/9 is just going to be
equal to negative 9 so you have a
negative 9e lasted price elasticity of
demand
so before I interpret that more let's
look at the price elasticity of demand
at other points or starting from other
points two other points on this curve so
let's think about it going from actually
let's think about it going from E to F
so as we go from E to F we're going to
do the same exact exercise what is our
percent change in quantity well our
initial quantity is 16 and we're going
from 16 to 18 so we have a change in two
of two so 2 over 16 times 100 percent
that is our percent change in quantity
and what is our percent change in price
well our initial price is two and we're
going from two to one so we have a price
change of negative one times 100% and so
what you see here is this is 1/8 times
100% this would be 12.5% up here so this
is 12.5% up there and then this over
here is going to be negative 50 percent
so when price went down by 50% you had a
12 and a half percent increase in
quantity 12.5% is 1/4 of 50% so this is
going to give us a price elasticity a
price elasticity of demand of negative
0.25 so there's a couple of interesting
things that you might already be
realizing one is even though our demand
curve right over here is a line it
actually has a constant slope you see
that the price elasticity of demand
changes depending on different parts of
the curve
now the reason why this is is really
just boils down to math when we're going
from A to B our initial prices were
relatively high so even though you had a
price decrease of 1 it was from an
initial price of 9 so your percentage
change in price looked fairly low while
your percentage change in quantity was
high because you're going from a low
quantity of 2 and you're adding 2 to it
so you had a hundred percent change in
quantity when you go to the other end of
our curve and you go from E to F it's
the other way around
your price starting point is low so your
percent change in price when you
decrease price by one it looks like a
fairly large magnitude while your
percent change in quantity when you go
from E to F because you are already at a
quantity of 16 adding 2 to that is not
that large of a percentage now another
thing you might be appreciating is if we
tried to calculate the price elasticity
of demand up here on the curve and
instead of going from A to B if we went
from bead a we would have gotten a
different value because our initial
prices and quantities would have been
different
our initial price we would have put an 8
over here and our initial quantity we
would have put a four over here and we
would have gotten a different value and
that's one of the negatives of the
technique which is arguably the simplest
technique that I just used there's other
techniques like the midpoint technique
that can give you a more consistent
result whether you're going from A to B
or B to a but I won't cover it just yet
but let's think now about how to
interpret this and the best way to
interpret it is to think about the
absolute value of the price elasticity
of demand so over here the absolute
value of our price elasticity of demand
is equal to nine and then over here the
absolute value of our price elasticity
of demand is equal to 0.25 and a general
rule of thumb is if your absolute value
of your price elasticity of demand is
less than one you are dealing with an
inelastic in elastic elastic situation
and if your price elasticity of demand
the absolute value of it is greater than
one you're dealing with an elastic
situation why does that make sense well
in this first scenario it's saying for a
given percentage change in price you
have a smaller percent change in
quantity while here for a given percent
in price you're going to have a larger
than that percentage change in your
quantity so once again it goes back to
these rubberband analogies so when we're
going from A to B the absolute value of
our price elasticity of demand is
definitely larger than one so economists
would consider this to be an elastic
situation while when we go from point A
to point EV our price elasticity of
demand or the absolute value of it is
definitely less than one so this is
going to be an in elastic situation